from pulse-pounding chases and alien
encounters to genre defining moments and
eye-popping animation these science
fiction movies know exactly how to start
off with a bang
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 A Space Odyssey
is full of moments that have permeated
pop culture there's the mysterious
Starchild the ancient discovery of the
monolith and the murderous HAL 9000
refusing to open the pod bay doors and
of course right up there with all those
iconic scenes is the opening sequence in
which the celestial bodies align the
film opens on the dark side of the moon
and the camera slowly pans up revealing
the Earth shrouded in the darkness of
space but then the sun begins to rise on
the far side of the world Illuminating
the entire shot the Grandeur of the
universe is on display but what really
sells the moment is the booming
bombastic music Kubrick famously chose
to score the film with classical
compositions and here he uses the spake
zarathustra by Richard Strauss without
that song to punctuate the scene this
opening just wouldn't have worked
believe it or not at first Kubrick
intended to use a completely original
score for the film written by Alex North
had composed music for films like
Spartacus and A Streetcar Named Desire
but his score for 2001 just wasn't
hitting right so Kubrick decided to get
classical by using a piece written in
1896 for a film released in 1968 Kubrick
created an opening that's become
absolutely timeless
the first image of The Prestige is a
strange one a forest floor littered with
top hats it's a bizarre compelling sight
and a devastating one if you've seen
this Christopher Nolan flick before
after that Christian bill has a question
for us are you watching closely Michael
Caine's character cutter then gives us a
magic lesson according to him there are
three key parts to any good magic trick
The Pledge the turn and the prestige but
as he tells us exactly how to wow an
audience we watch helplessly as Hugh
Jackman the Great Danton meets an
unexpected fate under the narration the
film Cuts back and forth between two
magic acts in one cutter makes a canary
disappear and reappear to the Delight of
a little girl and in the second a
wrapped audience watches as the Great
Danton steps into a Strange Electric
machine and vanishes naturally the
audience is baffled except for one
curious spectator whose stepped
backstage to discover the secret there
he watches Danton fall through a trap
door and into an ominous water tank the
lids swing shut and The Spectator just
watches as the magician drowns so what's
the deal with all those hats why is
there a water tank beneath the stage and
why is Christian Bale's character
treating Hugh Jackman so cruelly like
any good magic trick the opening scene
shows us something extraordinary and
keeps us guessing until the grand reveal
Spielberg sure knows how to start a
movie from Jaws to Raiders of the Lost
Ark his openings grab you by the collar
and never let go and even though E.T the
Extraterrestrial is meant for a
considerably younger audience it's
definitely no exception this 1982
classic begins with a spaceship parked
in a foggy California Forest its
adorable crew waddling around and
collecting plants these aliens aren't
here to harm us they're just
Intergalactic botanists having the time
of their lives among the Redwoods that's
especially true for E.T who's wandered
away from his buddies to find the
perfect sampling the peaceful scene is
shattered when a bunch of scary
scientists roll up in their oversized
trucks these guys Tower over E.T and he
watches in Terror as they Hustle by him
with their blinding flashlights and
jangling keys once they spot him the
terrified alien takes off running with
the humans in Hot Pursuit he desperately
tries to get back to the ship before it
takes off but it's too late et's buddies
are forced to take flight and leave
their frightened comrade behind mind
with John Williams score driving the
emotions home
ET shows just how quickly a good day can
turn into a bad one there's barely any
dialogue in this entire sequence but
that doesn't matter we're glued to the
screen anyway
you thought we could only pick one
Spielberg opening think again
Spielberg's 1993 classic Jurassic Park
starts off with a bang rather a roar we
open on something huge moving through a
clump of trees maybe it's a T-Rex well
not so fast instead it's a forklift
rolling through the jungle carrying a
massive cage with something angry inside
inside that cage is one of the most
terrifying dinos in the entire film the
Velociraptor it's smart sadistic and it
keeps on shrieking but we don't get a
good look at it yet that only makes it
scarier when the Jurassic Park crew
armed to the teeth tries to move the
creature from its cage to a fortified
pen if anybody slips up there's going to
be human meat on the menu naturally
disaster strikes as the cage door opens
the Raptor snags an unlucky worker by
the legs hoping for a midnight snack
springing into action game warden Robert
Muldoon grabs the man by the Torso
finding himself in a mortal game of tug
of war he issues his men a single
command loud and clear
this opening sequence perfectly sums up
the theme of the movie screw around with
nature and you'll wind up Dino dinner
everything about the Matrix is pretty
much perfect from the characters and
Kung Fu to the philosophical Concepts at
its heart that goes double for the
opening scene which starts with a wall
of digital green text and a mysterious
phone call about someone named the one
cut to a group of cops working their way
through a dank apartment complex ready
to arrest the leather clad Trinity but
when they try to handcuff her she turns
into Bruce Lee the camera freezes as
Trinity leaps into the air and delivers
the front kick that sends a cop flying
after that it's hard to keep up as she
runs on walls and kills everybody in the
room but while mere mortals can't stand
up to her martial arts skills even
Trinity gets freaked out when the agents
arrive with their dark glasses and
monotone voices it's clear from the jump
that there's something strange about
these guys and unlike the police they
can match Trinity's superhuman abilities
when she makes an impossible jump from
rooftop to Rooftop an agent follows her
with ease leaving a group of stunned
cops behind to put a final final
question mark on the sequence Trinity
evades her pursuers by disappearing into
a pay phone there's so many questions to
ask who are these people what's the deal
with their super ninja powers and who
exactly is the one by the time this
chaotic scene is over we're ready to
take the red pill and find out what's
really going on
Mad Max Fury Road is one big car chase
that never lets off the gas and the
action gets going from the very first
scene bearded and bedraggled Max
rocketanski stands in the desert
chomping on a mutant lizard and trying
to ignore the voices in his head
suddenly he hops into his car and peels
off into the desert followed by an army
of War Boys in their tricked out
Vehicles the painted Warriors capture
Max and drag him back to their hellish
Citadel where they shave his head and
tattoo his back but before they can
brand him as their slave Max makes a
last-ditch escape attempt the scene
plays out like a nightmare Max is lost
in a labyrinth the war boys are like
monstrous Ghouls and every time Max
turns a corner he's confronted by
visions of the people he couldn't save
finally Max makes a mad leap to freedom
but it's all for naught the freakish
flailing War boys drag him back inside
and suddenly
foreign
in just a few seconds we know everything
we need to know about Max he's a man
haunted by the dead and hunted by the
living and thanks to that frenetic
opening sequence were buckled in and
ready for this wild road trip
Paul verhoven was not a fan of Robert
heinlein's novel Starship Troopers so
much so that he decided to make it into
a movie in verhoven's version though any
seriousness is Stripped Away to show us
a wildly fascist world that just loves
being well fascist this satire of
authoritarianism is most effective in
the segments framed as Federal Network
propaganda videos which all end with the
iconic caption would you like to know
more the film opens with the first of
these Federal Network videos a military
recruitment ad with shots directly
imitating those in the Nazi propaganda
film Triumph of the will from the very
beginning we can tell that this is a
society that doesn't seem to mind
forever Wars or child soldiers I'm doing
my part I'm doing my part I'm doing my
part
I'm doing my part too
videos calling for Humanity to
completely eradicate the clandazu bug
aliens show how questionable the
government's excuse for this war seems
to be a news report on Battlefield
introduces some of verhoven's signature
over-the-top violence with multiple
soldiers and journalists getting
massacred by giant bugs while the satire
of Starship Troopers was largely
misunderstood at the time of its release
the film has since been Revisited and
reappraised with a true understanding of
the message verhoven was actually trying
to convey Terminator 2 Judgment Day is a
bigger and debatably better movie than
the first Terminator in every way
imaginable and that starts from the very
beginning the 1984 original introduces
its post-apocalyptic future with a few
iconic images a ship flying over a
decimated City the Treads of a tank
crushing human skulls and a soldier
running from laser fire the 1991 sequels
opening scene takes the war against the
machines and pushes it to the next level
the t2 prologue has more ships more
soldiers and more skeletons the
massively increased effects budget
allows for more action like big
explosions and clear views of machines
in battle still James Cameron's
improvements between films are not
merely in terms of spectacle but in
terms of emotion as well before flashing
forward to the war in the future we see
glimpses of a pre-apocalyptic Los
Angeles where children laugh on a
playground just before the bombs go off
the narration by Sarah Connor sets up
the sequel's story of the resistance
sending a loan Warrior to protect her
son John in the past while still keeping
it a secret that this protector happens
to be another Terminator
while the ending of M Night shyamalan's
signs is maligned by many it's opening
perfectly sets up the Eerie tone of the
rest of the film this Alien Invasion
flick starts with a shot of a peaceful
Farm the sun is shining the Grasshoppers
are chirping it should feel like a
wonderful day but something's off and
Graham Hess knows it he wakes up from a
bad dream to hear his daughter screaming
outside this is not a good way to start
the day the confused dad and his
concerned brother rush into the farmyard
looking for the source of the screams
the two men plunge into the cornfield
rushing down an empty rope until they
find the little girl in a daze she
thinks she's still dreaming and honestly
she might as well be she isn't alone
either her older brother is just a few
feet ahead staring into the field and
Whispering creepy things
think God did it
and what did God do something huge has
trampled down massive swaths of corn
without breaking a single stalk as the
camera pulls back we see his field is
full of circles of flattened corn
creating a massive otherworldly shape
it's a crop circle evidence of aliens
lurking about and his gram stares in
bewilderment we know this is a sign of
bad things to come
did audiences know they were watching
the birth of a legendary franchise when
they saw Star Wars A New Hope Premiere
in 1977 maybe maybe not but they
definitely knew they were watching one
of the most exciting sci-fi
introductions of the 20th century when
the film kicked off after the
unforgettable opening crawl Fades Away
George Lucas puts his incredible visual
storytelling skills on display we see a
tiny Rebel Ship flying overhead as fast
as it can trying to escape the Empire's
Star Destroyer while the rebel vessel
just whizzes on by the Star Destroyer is
so massive that it takes nearly 10
seconds for the entire ship to enter the
frame the symbolism here is simple and
smart the Rebel Alliance is Tiny and
outmatched while the Empire is
absolutely enormous it's David and
Goliath in space and the odds are
stacked against our heroes no matter how
hard you try you can't outrun the Empire
so it's up to our heroes to fight
what do you do when you're trapped in a
no-win situation that's the question
posed in the first few minutes of Star
Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan in the opening
of this 1982 classic we're introduced to
beloved characters from the TV show like
Spock and Uhura but Kirk isn't calling
the shots this time there's a new
captain on the Enterprise lieutenant
savik and she finds herself in quite the
conundrum when she receives a distress
signal from the Kobayashi Maru the ship
is stranded in the neutral zone a Space
Border separating the Federation and the
Klingon Empire if sovik flees into the
buffer the Klingons will attack but
there are hundreds of people aboard the
kobayashimaru and if sovik doesn't help
they'll die sovik makes the brave choice
to save lives but the moment she breaks
the treaty the Klingons blow the
Enterprise to Kingdom Come seemingly
killing everyone aboard that's when Kirk
appears revealing that this isn't really
the Enterprise and there is no
kobayashimaru and all those Dead
characters they're perfectly fine the
whole thing was a training exercise to
test up-and-coming Starfleet officers by
putting them in no win situations and no
win situations the possibility every
Commander May face has that never
occurred to you no sir it is not it's an
unexpected opening and it brilliantly
foreshadows the impossible scenario Kirk
finds himself in later on in addition to
setting the stakes the opening fooled
fans who'd been spoiled by hearing that
Spock was meant to die in the film by
fake killing him in the first few
minutes the filmmakers tricked trekkies
into thinking the Spock death rumors
were exaggerated before breaking their
hearts for real in the Final Act
a strong opening scene should make us
wonder what's going on and what will
happen next the thing raises questions
from the very first shot after we
witness a UFO heading for earth the
movie cuts to the Frozen Wasteland of
Antarctica as John Carpenter's synth
heavy score sets the mood a helicopter
cuts through the sky the men inside are
on the lookout searching for something
in the snow and that's when we see what
they're chasing down below a husky is
running for its life with a helicopter
in full Pursuit stranger still the man
in the chopper starts firing at the mutt
with a rifle obviously most people don't
go flying around trying to pick off
puppies from the air in fact if we
didn't know any better we'd say this guy
was some sort of monster but maybe it
isn't the human Who's acting like an
alien what would Inspire someone to grab
a gun and go hunting Huskies perhaps
there's more to this dog than meets the
eye as it flees to a nearby base we're
sitting on the edge of our seats
intrigued and terrified to see what will
happen with this creepy canine directed
by Paul verhoven and based on a story by
Philip K dick Total Recall really wants
to screw with your mind this 1990 film
plays with the concept of memory making
us question what's real and what's all
in Arnold Schwarzenegger's head the
opening sequence is no exception is it a
dream or a memory whatever's going on
it's pretty freaky and involves a lot of
loud Schwarzenegger noises everything
starts and ends on the planet Mars it's
red and Dusty and completely Barren
except for two humans walking along a
ridge Douglas Quaid and a mysterious
woman are admiring The View and holding
hands clearly a couple on some sort of
space vacation but the fun comes to a
halt when the ground gives way and Quade
tumbles down into the valley below his
helmet shatters on a rock and things
take a turn for the grotesque
foreign
may be back in the safety of his own
home after waking up but not for long
he'll soon find himself back on the
surface of the red planet the opening of
Total Recall is an unsettling beginning
to a mysterious film one that's provided
plenty of nightmare fuel for countless
sci-fi fans
directed by Edgar Wright The World's End
starts in the Glorious Days of
yesteryear as Gary King whacks his
lyrical about the best moment of his
life it was 1990 back when Gary was king
of his high school and one fateful night
he and his mates set off on a drunken
Adventure in their hometown of Newton
Haven the plan to complete the Golden
Mile pub crawl along the way they pick
up girls get into brawls and revel in
their youth in true Edgar Wright fashion
this four minute prologue sets up
everything that will happen to Gary and
his buddies when they return to Newton
Haven as adults if you're watching
closely you can even spot a UFO flying
in the distance signaling the arrival of
the villainous Network everything is
brilliant and fun until the past meets
the present and modern day Gary is
telling his story at rehab suddenly he's
a much more depressing figure an
alcoholic who peaked as a teenager who's
now desperate to relive that pub crawl
and get wasted yet again like the film
itself the opening walks the line
between happy and heartbreaking and it
perfectly lays out all the drunken chaos
to come
the first 13 minutes of Alfonso
quarron's seven-time oscar-winner
gravity are so beautiful and heart
poundingly intense that the scene
probably still would have won awards if
it was released on its own as a short
film expanding upon what Quran and
cinematographer Emmanuel lubesky
accomplished in Children of Men the
opening of gravity is presented as one
single take with no Cuts Dr Ryan Stone
and Lieutenant Matt Kowalski are
repairing the Hubble Space Telescope
when an Urgent Message from Mission
Control tells them to return to Earth an
exploded satellite has launched debris
in their Direction the warning doesn't
come soon enough though and the storm of
satellite Parts destroys the space
shuttle and sends the astronauts
tumbling through space the CGI effects
used to depict this horrific event are
still frighteningly convincing years
later there's a reason gravity swept the
technical categories at the Academy
Awards it's truly completely stunning
you admit one thing
can't beat The View forget the best
first scenes Wally might just have the
best opening half hour of any science
fiction project and for many it's up
there with the best first acts in any
genre understand's 2008 Pixar movie is
entertaining and moving throughout but
it's at its most impressive in its first
third with extremely minimal dialogue we
follow the lonely trash compactor robot
Wally as he scavenges through a polluted
post-apocalyptic Earth and falls in love
with the more advanced visiting Droid
Eve the opening scene of Wall-E is set
to the song put on your Sunday clothes
from the musical Hello Dolly the Majesty
of the initial images of space gives way
to a sense of both irony and horror when
the camera Zooms in on our abandoned
garbage covered earth when we realize
the music is coming from Wally's own
speakers it immediately establishes our
adorable protagonist as a romantic who's
managed to find Joy amidst the detrius
of our ruined civilization
Akira kasuhiro otomo's 1988 adaptation
of his own manga introduced people
around the world to the art form of
anime and became a massive influence on
the Sci-Fi genre hit films like the
Matrix Looper and Chronicle all oh a
massive debt to atomos Classic Akira
probably wouldn't have been such a hit
if it didn't keep viewers glued to the
screen from the very first moment before
a title card or even any sound drops in
we see Tokyo enveloped in a blinding
explosion that striking opening shot is
followed by a thrilling introduction to
life in Neo Tokyo in 2019 31 years after
World War III a man walks past a damaged
car into a graffiti-covered bar news
reports on the TV explained that mass
unemployment has led to riots
protagonist Canada is hanging out by the
Jukebox when he's dragged out to join a
fight with the Rival clown gang Canada's
first interactions with his fellow gang
member tetsuo established the character
conflicts that will blow up over the
course of the film and then course
there's the motorcycle chase that
opening Pursuit is the first thing most
people think of when they think of Akira
and for good reason it's basically
unmatched in its combination of detail
and fluidity in its animation and of
course it has that famous bike slide
that's been emulated in countless other
movies and shows
if any any opening scene can rival
akiras in terms of energetic Thrills and
visual accomplishment it's the race that
opens Takeshi koike's Redline debuting
at film festivals in 2009 a year before
its release in Japanese theaters Redline
is campier than Akira but it's also a
thrilling experience that never lets up
on the gas the film opens in the final
leg of the yellow line qualifying race
with protagonist sweet JP in 7th place
JP does things old school in his own way
driving his souped-up TransAm in
competition with futuristic hover cars
the racist commentator has counted him
out but this big haired Speed Demon
won't let anyone get him down I'm just
trying to keep this thing interesting
can't write me off like that you're just
a voice pal you don't know a damn thing
about racing JP gets incredibly close to
winning something he's not supposed to
do considering that the mafia has rigged
the competition JP's alien mechanic
frisbee has to activate a remote bomb to
stop JP from winning causing a massive
wreck and allowing future love interest
sonoshi McLaren to win the race and
advance to the red line vehicles in
modern anime are almost always animated
with CGI these days but the vehicles in
Redline are all hand drawn as a result
the movie took seven years to make and
nearly put its Studio out of business
even though it flopped at the box office
it's impossible to ignore the passion
that went into this Nitro boosted labor
of love is Valerian and the City of a
thousand planets a good movie that's Up
For Debate Luke pasone's 2017 Space
Opera features some stunning imagery but
it's undeniable that leads Dane Dahan
and Cara Delevingne are seriously
lacking in chemistry before we ever
catch a glimpse of valerian and his
partner laureline though audiences are
treated to one of the most uplifting and
delightful openings that contemporary
sci-fi has to offer the film opens on
the International Space Station a symbol
of humankind's cooperation in the quest
to research the cosmos American
astronauts meet with representatives
from all over the world and the station
becomes increasing diverse as it also
grows in size then in 2150 we make first
Contact an advanced alien race arrives
at the ISS but they're anything but
hostile over hundreds of years new
species continue to come to the station
shaking hands with human representatives
and adding their ships to the station as
they arrive in fact the station grows so
large that it must be launched out of
Earth's orbit entirely and as it makes
its way to the Magellan current it
becomes the titular city of a thousand
planets the whole thing is set to the
tune of David Bowie's incredible Space
Oddity the beginning of valerian is a
beautiful reminder that when we put
aside our petty differences and work
together people can do some truly
fantastic things
[Music]
foreign